that bruce springsteen video do you
listen to that song at all if you if
that comes on the radio do you go like i
don't want to hear that
or or is that still important to you
that song dancing in the dark well bruce
springsteen is such a i mean he's god
he's so incredible i love that song i
get a little embarrassed because i do
feel like when i watch the video when i
see it
i mean god i felt i mean did you see my
dance it was pathetic i'm not a bad
dancer but that was horrible
i was so nervous when you uh went in for
the audition there was an audition of
all professional dancers they were all
warming up doing their stretches and
stuff and you walked in and like they're
not going to pick me well i thought i
was in the wrong place
yeah i was like what what's i i don't
know what they're doing but i can't even
bend my leg like this is it
so i uh
i went into brian de palma's office he
put on the music and said well you dance
and i i thought right now here in front
of you just the two of us
and it was so embarrassing i think
that's why i got it because i was
literally like okay
and um i think that's what they wanted a
fan that just
couldn't believe it